this is not going anywhere this podcast
right i can't i can't i
know we have to continue some other time
no no we're going to do a little bit
more time
it's terrible i can't do it i i'm just
not
everything i'm saying is not good and
i'm just going yeah yeah
you're fine no it's not it's not good i
feel you it's it's tough
no you don't i'm not adding an
information for some reason i'm just
kind of like
lost and i don't know what to say i
don't know what every
story i had to cut around because i've
already said it a thousand times it's
like
i've done so many podcasts it's like you
just you know i know i know years it's
like
you just kind of get to a point where
it's like what else is there to say
i don't know what else to say i don't
live in we can live in the conversation
at the moment
and let it go where it is i know but
it's like it's like sometimes it's like
i don't know
we went into matching mountain rides
that was ridiculous
and it was really kind of fun and then
like
it's drifting in and out of different
things that don't really make any
kind of sense to me of why anyone would
give a [ __ ]
it's amazing to me that anybody gives a
[ __ ] general and they do you know
what i mean
like who gives a [ __ ] they do they like
it
this is your existential moment yeah
you're really having a crisis right now
do you do this on belly
no because um no because there's a guest
he turns around plays video games
that's not it is it's and belly it's
different because it's like we talk
about
belly's different because we talk about
what's going on in the house
also we have a guest you know the guest
and then we also
it's it's also i always tell like
it's just different you know this one
the pressure is
is more there's no pressure on that one
because
this one you know it's like you're so
good that like
you know i just sometimes i just kind of
go
i don't want to i don't know what i'm
doing
you don't want to do it anymore no i
want to do it i just
of course i want to do it no i know you
know i mean i just don't know what i'm
doing right now
well let's get to another let's get to
another point and then we can we can
always do is create
a little break or something smoke a
cigarette and that'll help me
look at me look at me look at me sweet
boy anyone cares
well you're doing good why are you
having this existential weird moment
you don't know what anything means
really let's talk about that
i don't know what anything means i don't
know anything
that's another thing is i realize i
don't know anything
i don't no i really don't know
i don't know anything about anything i
don't know how anything works i don't
know
what i believe in i don't know you know
how long i have left what am i doing
with the time that i have
you know what is this
i mean genuinely do you mean this yeah
i have these moments of just like what
would you rather be doing
even when i'm playing video games i'm
like this isn't it
what do you think you should be doing
failing your time that's the thing
there's got to be
you're having kind of like a midlife
crisis no i'm not
i think it has to do with like the
pandemic
because it's like i can't leave so it's
like i you know i can't leave
and i can't do anything i can't do
anything that i want to do
i can't do stand-up i can't do anything
so it's like my days are left of just
watching old star trek next generation
episodes
to trying to watch other things that you
know i mean that people are saying you
should watch
this this is great on netflix it's
trending number three
you know i mean and you just kind of
watch it this morning when i watched
that
reality show was just on i was watching
going this is
the day and this is going to end the
same as it did last night
and then it's like and then i realized
like what's the point of it all
there's nothing to do well and then i'm
going to hawaii
you know at the end of the week or when
a couple i don't know when i go you know
you know
but it's like
why we'll go what's the point because
there's a job there
yeah i know but um but let's i'm being
serious yeah
are you having this crisis moment
because you feel like you're you're not
being fulfilled
it's not just fulfilled it's what's the
point of it all well
let's go over the point there is no
point i hate this business
mm-hmm and i and uh let's get out and
i'm done
i think you're done in a week you're
going to hawaii to film another episode
of magnum
that's that's not in the business though
that is literally the business yeah but
when you show up there it's like
you realize they even go people watch
this like
it's not a thing like you know when i
did love yeah and should have patel's
around everyone's around
and they take them some seriously that
right there
to me is the business you know what i
mean so you prefer when people are
taking themselves
no i want to be a part of that group i
want to be a part of like the cool group
i want to be a part of like
you are in the cool group i'm not i'm in
the like ghetto [ __ ]
here's the problem that i think you're
mistaking most people aren't in
this fake group that you think people
are want to be in it you're not in it
and you want it because it doesn't exist
it does no because you ask them and
they'll even tell you i don't even know
what you're talking about
yeah those people want to be in it too
and you that's why you butt heads with
them
butt heads with who you know you're
talking about
who i know tell me who what's what's his
name seth
seth the guy that was in the disaster
artist what's his name
seth rogen yeah how do i butt heads what
are you talking about you got
you gave him [ __ ] about the lines and
the thing and then he no i
no i didn't give him [ __ ] about it i
publicly talked [ __ ] about not having
anything but you have to understand that
there was tension between you two you
said
no the idea was the idea was like
i don't think they cared that i was
bummed that i got taken out
so that made me sad it was a bummer then
you could approach him and then he was
like
weird with you no but no i didn't
approach him about the lines but the
next time i saw him it was kind of weird
yeah
are you weird now with him i haven't
seen him yeah
but you think there's weirdness do you
think he likes you i don't think he
cares about me as a i don't think he
gives a [ __ ] that i exi i don't i think
he
that's what it is i think he probably
there are people that he doesn't care
about well of course
yeah no but i'm okay with that i just
think that he goes
that kid's nice kind of funny it didn't
work out with us
no i don't think he cares but here's my
i got to start
i got to be a part of a group right
that's doing high level [ __ ]
that everyone wants to be a part of we
we make this show and people [ __ ]
love this show i know but i'm
i know i understand that that's great so
you want this to be highbrow and
[ __ ] no i don't want to harvard
lampoon [ __ ] no no i don't want to say
hi i know
but i want it like we're not smart
enough you and i are not that smart
that's what i'm saying what are we doing
this is great what did we do we were
dumb
yeah it's great what are we doing here
around we're gonna read something man
we're gonna learn about things we're
speaking for the idiots oh
god that's it that's what it means
we're dumb we're dumb but we've always
said we're dumb
oh and let me tell you something yeah i
don't want to be smart
because this is fun i'm having a great
[ __ ] time
being dumb with you is more fun than
anything i've done and it's
usually great it's usually you're in a
you're in a weird head space it's like
you know there are snooty pit parts
about me
yeah but you've been you've mentioned
that no i'm very snooty when it comes to
like
you mean i don't like these kind of
films or these kind of yeah you've
manufactured that
you've made that up and i've always
wanted to be a part of like the cool
group
and it's like even since i was in
[ __ ] high school i could never get in
i can never get in with the cool kids
here's the ir here's the irony and i
want to be in the cool kids now
name to me the cool kids because they
were the dorks for sure
who you think are the cool kids are
we're dorks i know
so what are you even talking about you
don't want to be friends with them
whoever you're talking about they don't
exist i know you you make up the idea
that there's this group that you would
join and hang out with but it's not
you know i do these podcasts because
it was the last thing that i could do to
survive
at the beginning oh yeah it was the la
it was like oh it's either this or get a
day job
but now you do the podcast my point is
is that
so it's the podcasting stuff isn't you
know
i love doing it saved me like in a way
right but it's like
it wasn't you know why i came to l.a why
did you come to la
i thought that i honestly thought that i
would be a movie star
but that's not that's but that's not
that's not a real thought
but that's one of my go that was my
dream like i'm gonna be a movie star and
i'm gonna do these i'm gonna do all this
stuff
but you are off working act readjust
your dream then i know i'm gonna have to
but my point is
and so every once in a while and people
think that i'm complaining or
whining i'm not whining i'm just you
know i'm just it gets to a point where
you're just kind of like
what the [ __ ] am i doing you know and it
has to do with the pandemic too it's
like you know
i don't we're like here's another thing
and this is
a part of my thing is you know every
once in a while i like to go buy clothes
i know you know i haven't i have this
weird obsession with like
you know i'll go you know i'll go to
self edge and maybe i'll get a new
you know i mean japanese raw denim you
know i mean i'll wear it out this year
i'll just wear it every day right and
get the creases and make it right
right and so i i've you look at my
emails i've ordered ten thousand things
online and they have none of them come
yeah none of it's coming so i can't even
do that
i'm just saying every morning i wake up
right and i
go out to the balcony because from the
balcony i can look down to see
like packages yeah and there's all these
gigantic boxes filled with like ottomans
and chairs that [ __ ] kolila gets
right or lamp fixtures right right i'm
just looking for that little tiny
jacket you know or you know i mean or
you know i mean the underwear that i
bought
right you know i mean or the socks or
whatever right and it's that they and
they say it's delivering to track your
but i don't know how to do any of that
right right so i don't know how to track
it i don't know where it is
i mean i have things i bought a [ __ ]
you know that couch a french
italian couch i have right a part of
that deal
i bought these really cool light things
right they're like light fixtures right
and i remember a year ago when i bought
the [ __ ] italian couch i said um
hey do you think you can throw in one of
those fancy light fixtures
ah no problem buddy yo how many do you
want
i go four great man there's only four
left anyway
and then you know we got the italian
couch and i go clyde where's the atlanta
pictures
she goes it's somewhere in culver city
and something
and i go i guess i'll never get it you
didn't get it you know what i mean this
sound this sounds so i don't have
it's just you're not getting you're
you're not getting things during
anything
i can't get anything so it's like
the frustration is obvious i'm so
sensitive i guess because of this
pandemic because of that
i think that's a part of so i can't take
any kind of criticism criticism but
that's okay
yeah because we're going to get through
it and it's going to be fine on the
other hand like
i'm i'm just a jumbled of nerves
you need a release yeah there's nothing
you know and you know that's so rude to
me at the house you know i mean
that i can feel yeah they're so rude to
me at the house when you say you're king
and she goes i want you're not my king
right yeah i go tell me how you're king
you know do i not say that who's the
king
and you won't tell me you're the king
unless i threaten you yeah yeah
who is the king
that's what i'm saying that's
interesting yeah and she's not the king
can i die
but it's not i i i i i i i i
let me i i i i you you you think that
like when i was
first of all you know what i mean i'm
usually uh you know where i go it's okay
no no no no no you don't know what's
going on i'm so sorry about my
existential i'm going through look at me
look at me don't be sorry yeah
it's a great it's an honest moment that
you're having yeah
honestly this whole podcast i was just
like the whole time thing is what am i
doing here
sometimes your mind gets in those things
why what are we saying yeah you're
you're becoming like a nihilist you know
i no i'm not no i'm not i'm just
i'm literally going why would anyone
want to listen to this too you think i
don't know yeah yeah but they do
and i appreciate it yeah yeah and i i
i'm appreciative i love
when they call in the guy with gigantism
and the dwarves and all the people that
and the lady and everyone calling in and
going get them in i mean we love you
know i mean
keep going and they buy the merch but
you know and they
they tag me in it and they make little
videos of me it's really sweet and i
really
appreciate it and i go but deep down i'm
going why do you like it
you know i mean i'm glad you do i'm
going to keep doing it because
you know there's nothing else to do do
you like it i love doing it
yeah i like seeing you and i like doing
it yeah there are times where i'm like
oh that's a funny bit or you know i mean
oh that we really
yeah i mean yeah we went this way with
it yeah and that was fun right
but today was not it no today was just
like oh that's not
it i'm glad we had i mean a lot of it
was great yeah
right george short all right
hey thank you for being a bad friend
you know people people were worried that
we were gonna stop the show
why because you're your existential
crisis that you had on the show
people are like they're gonna stop it's
gonna be over and then people watch
tiger belly and they were like what did
you say to bobby what did you do to
bobby
nothing dude
to do and let me say this i didn't know
what i said last time
i don't know either let me say this what
i missed you a lot when you're in hawaii
oh my god i thought about you every day
i had one nightmare about you what is it
i had a nightmare you died in hawaii and
i didn't call you
but i was going to call you to tell you
i'm not kidding i had a nightmare you
got hit by a car
yeah walking to dinner did you walk to
dinner one night
every night there's no one so where else
am i gonna go so i'm psychic
you were walking to dinner you got hit
by a like a you know those three wheeled
cars
two in the back one in the front yeah
hawaii they're all over the place
yeah yeah you get hit by one yeah and a
big kawana guy gets
you know oh bro i didn't see you bro
yeah yeah yeah i'm coming back from the
coffee
or the pineapple whatever yeah yeah and
you're like and you were and you were
all twisted up
and he was like [ __ ] dude i think you're
dying bro
and you were like i am and you could
tell you were dying
and he said any last words and you were
like
tell andrew santino i'm sorry and that i
love him
and he means the world to me and then
you were out and then you died
and i woke up
and i ran to my phone and i was gonna
text you
but i didn't
and i knew you were okay
all right andres what's the game no let
me just let me let me add on to that
please
give me an opportunity and
just to let the fans know let the fans
know
that number one i didn't
i don't remember i know what i did last
time yeah you had like a breakdown
almost it was okay
no it was honest it was great fine i'm
just i'm honest today yeah
so i don't know i remember number two um
that was also because we had to backlog
so we just got to the point where
we were doing too many episodes just you
know you do tiger belly and then i do
and you do whiskey and we do so many in
a week it was a lot eventually it's like
you go you just go i don't know what
else to [ __ ] say well yeah even you
know i don't even know
we were dumb we were doing too many with
too many and also it's like you need to
you know take breaks so you can you know
re-energize 100
so uh anyway and number two um
you're not you the only way this will
end you know i mean is if um
we just physically can't do it anymore
in terms of like we're too busy
or you know or somebody dies or
something happens
i mean i have been thinking about death
in hawaii a lot you know i i downloaded
a
book called the certainty of death yeah
it was written i forgot it wasn't it in
the 70s
you know i've been thinking about death
a lot so that's not no truthfully i did
have a dream
it was really weird that you say that
because i i've never
thought about death as much as i did
when when i was in hawaii that's why i
had a dream
it's really weird we are connected
look at me hey don't look at me in the
eye you can see whatever you want i want
to look at you though look at me in the
eyes
please
so what i'm saying is what were you
thinking about dying but i did have a
dream about you died in hawaii is weird
and and what here's what got me out of
it
yeah and this is real so i was thinking
about death all the time because you
have when you have eight days off
and you're alone what are you doing what
are you doing you just walking around
netflix
start thinking about death yeah and then
i i said
okay so i'm 49 you know um
i'm not the healthiest guy in the world
let's just you know you're not unhealthy
yeah but let's say maradona died you
know maradona correct
he died and he was 60. he just recently
died a couple of months ago
yeah let's suppose i'm like because he
has the same body as i do too maragona
he's a little soft yeah yeah no he's
just you know roly-poly-ish you know
yeah he did a lot of he we haven't had
he did a lot of drugs he doesn't eat
well
so i said if i if so i'm just going to
take every moment
and just milk every moment
and just be grounded in in in the
present moment
that's cool it's the only way to do it
that's awesome if you start thinking
about death
then it's your whole day is fun